vamos a decir que el pib nominal del
2011 fue de 15 mil 290 y 4.3 billones de
dólares bueno de hecho estamos no
estamos suponiendo este es un dato real
es un estimado del pib nominal del 2011
para la cuarta parte del año ahora el
término nominal aquí hace referencia a
que el pib de cada uno de los países es
convertido de sus respectivas monedas
nacionales a dólares estadounidenses
según sean las tasas correspondientes a
un promedio anual siempre es importante
saber con respecto a qué año estás
tomando tu deflactor aquí es el
deflactor del pib relativo al año 2010
es de 102.5 deflactor del pib del 2011
relativo al 2010 es de 102.5 para
interpretarlo si tomamos al 2010 como
año base eso significa que por ejemplo
si estaban en 100 los precios ahora que
estamos en el 2011 están en ciento 2.5 y
lo que estamos diciendo lo que estamos
interpretando es que el nivel general de
los precios subió está
en 100 y ahora en 102.5 es decir que
subieron por 2.5 por ciento y sabiendo
todo esto vamos a juntar toda la
información ahora ya conocemos el pib
nominal del año 2011 es de 15 mil 290 y
4.3 millones y también conocemos el
deflactor del año 2011 relativo al 2010
así que ahora averigüemos el pib real
para el año 2011 y luego también
relativo al año 2010 con moneda del año
2010 y para hacer esto recordemos la
siguiente razón entre nuestro pib
nominal y nuestro pib real el pib
nominal sobre pib real esta razón será
igual a lo puedes ver como nuestros
dólares de hoy en día contra los dólares
del año 2010 o también lo puedes ver
como la razón esta razón es igual a el
deflactor nuestro deflactor que es igual
a 102 punto 5 sobre 100 y de hecho esto
aquí es el deflactor del año 2010
estamos ajustando los niveles de los
precios hacer 100 y el deflactor es de
102.5 y viéndolo de esta manera nuestro
pib nominal
dinero de hoy es de 15.000 es de 15 mil
290 y 4.3 billones billones de dólares y
queremos saber queremos calcular nuestro
pib real esto de aquí no lo sabemos no
sabemos cuál es nuestro pib real ahora
nuestro deflactor lo conocemos sabemos
que todo subió por 2.5 por ciento en
precios o lo que es lo mismo el
deflactor es de 102.5 y bueno ahora todo
está muy sencillo ya podemos resolver
para conocer el pib real tenemos 102.5
entre 100 esa expresión de ahí es igual
a 1.0 25 1.0 25 y luego tenemos acá
estos 15 billones divididos por el pib
real eso es igual a 1.0 25 o podemos
dividir ambos lados del asunto por el
1.0 25 luego multiplicar a ambos lados
por el pib real así que vamos a hacer
eso hagamos eso multiplicamos aquí vamos
a multiplicar ambos lados por el pib
real por aquí y también por acá
y claro dividimos ambos lados por el
numerito s 1.0 25 entonces aquí 1.0 25 y
también acá 1.0 25 y bueno ahora estos
dos se cancelan se cancelan por eso
multiplique por el pib real y también
acá estos dos se cancelan ahora que
tenemos por fin que tenemos nuestro pib
ya tenemos nuestro pib o long lo va por
el mejor en azul menos un mejor porque
así es como lo hemos estado manejando a
nuestro pib es igual a nuestro pib
nominal que es 15000 15.290 y 4.3
billones de dólares / esencialmente
nuestro deflector sobre 100 que es 1.0
25 ahora bien si yo estuviera a cargo de
nombrar conceptos de microeconomía lo
que haría yo es nombrar a estos
deflactor esto lo mandó a uno y aquí
pongo directo 1.0 25 de esta manera yo
no tengo que lidiar con multiplicar y
dividir por 100 solamente digo bueno
tenemos aquí nuestro pib nominal lo
dividimos por el deflactor y así
obtenemos el pib real
para mí tiene mucho más sentido hacer
esto aunque bueno a este este es el
valor que llegamos este es el pib
nominal sobre lo que yo llamaría el
deflactor aunque lo puedes ver como el
deflactor sobre 100 y eso nos da nuestro
pib real y aquí tenemos algún monstruo
horrible este número
así que saquemos la calculadora para que
nos salve para resolverlo entonces aquí
estáis 15.294 15.290 y 4.3 billones
sobre sobre lo que es 1.1.0 25 nos da 14
mil 921 punto 3 voy a redondear lo
entonces voy a ponerlo por este otro
lado para escribirlo aquí adios
calculadora y bueno ya por fin tenemos
el cálculo del pib real nuestro pib real
es igual a 14.000 no aquí está mal
novecientos 21.3 millones
punto 3 billones aproximadamente
billones de dólares es nuestro pib real
o lo que es lo mismo si lo queremos ver
en trillones esto es equivalente en
trillones a es igual a 14.92 13
trillones de dólares es nuestro pib real